[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to CBS this morning you know rod
Rosen I was probably standing there
thinking if I move a muscle the
late-night comedians are gonna talk
about me and others and say I don't know
him never met him but it didn't look
like he wanted to be there no it's like
not to say anything but you say
everything and I'm gonna start by saying
this which is Anthony Mason is here
because Norah O'Donnell is off
Republicans say it is time to put the
Russia investigation in the past
Democrats have a different plan now that
the Robert Muller's report is out in the
public President Trump claims total
exoneration and Russia's government is
dismissing Muller's findings but the
special counsels 448 page report details
the president's repeated efforts to
stymie the investigation and how he was
stopped by the people around him mother
found no collusion with Russian
interfering with the election but he did
not decide the question of obstruction
of justice according to the report if
Muller's team could have definitely said
the president did not commit a crime
they would have Paula rediscovered this
investigation from the very beginning
she's at the White House with the latest
on this story Paula there is a lot to
discuss today good morning Gail there is
so much to discuss but of course we have
to make clear the president has not been
charged with any crime but according to
Robert Muller it's not for lack of
trying the special counsels report
yesterday laid out how often the people
around the president need to protect him
from his worst instincts in yesterday in
a press conference his Attorney General
William Barre often sounded like a
defense attorney offering a very
understanding interpretation of the
president's actions in May 2017
president Trump slumped in his chair in
the Oval Office and said robert muller
would be the end of his presidency
according to the special counsels
blockbuster report muller describes for
the first time an angry president
reacting to the appointment of a special
counsel i'm effed he told his then
attorney general jeff sessions who had
just relayed the news this is the worst
thing that has ever happened to me
but yesterday the president declared
victory over the investigations findings
i'm having a good day too
it was called no collusion no
obstruction
but that's not exactly what the report
said muller concluded the president did
not coordinate with Russia's efforts to
interfere in the 2016 election they have
one of the great memories of all time
though mr. Trump's written answers
surrounding Russia were considered
inadequate in nearly three dozen
instances the president said he could
not remember events Muller's account
details roughly two years of chaos in
which mr. Trump struggled to respond to
the Russia investigation and cites 10
episodes that could possibly constitute
obstruction in one example the report
states that in June 2017 the president
called former White House Counsel Don
Magan at least twice and told him to
have the special counsel fired Magan
recalled feeling trapped because he did
not plan to follow the president's
directive but did not know what he would
say the next time the president called
Magan decided he needed to resign the
report says the president's efforts to
influence the investigation were mostly
unsuccessful but that is largely because
the persons who surrounded the president
declined to carry out orders or cede to
his requests the special counsel
concluded it could not exonerate the
President on whether he obstructed
justice and it was Muller's boss
Attorney General William Barr who
cleared the President on that question
in a press conference yesterday Barr
defended his handling of the
investigation so what did you say to
people on both sides of the aisle
concerned that you were trying to
protect the statements about his is his
sincere beliefs are recognized in the
report that there was substantial
evidence for that so I'm not sure what
your basis is for saying that I am being
generous to the president the report
revealed prosecutors are pursuing 14
other matters referred by the special
counsel only two of those are known to
the public the investigation of Michael
Cohen as well as a separate
investigation into a former Obama
administration official but those 12
other mystery investigations ensure that
even though this report has been
submitted Muller shadow will continue to
loom large over this White House Anthony
Paula thanks